joining me now is Miranda Devine New
York Post columnist Fox News contributor
author of laptop from Hell keeps getting
more hellish and Mike Davis founder and
president of the internet accountability
project Miranda
now a lot of people watching might kind
of remember this Baker character but why
is he important and it's just come on
this is just a coincidence right I mean
so he goes to Twitter's Twitter's
employment so the top top executive
well James Baker was a good friend and
Ally of uh of course James Comey it was
Baker as the top lawyer at the FBI who
wrote the memo that exonerate prig
exonerated really Hillary Clinton he was
behind all the Russia collusion hoaxes
to try and get rid of Donald Trump and
uh in the end in 2018 Christopher Ray
basically threw him out of that general
counsel role and he shortly afterwards
resigned and he showed up at Twitter
strangely enough just five months before
the 2020 election and he was of course
right in the center of the decision to
censor the New York Post he of course
you won't be surprised to know was on
the side of censorship to ER on the side
of caution
well they also um Turned out Mike to the
FBI warned Twitter during these weekly
meetings before the 2020 election to
expect hack and leak operations by state
actors involving Hunter and likely in
October according to that sworn uh
declaration by Twitter's former head of
site Integrity Joel Roth how is that
important well it's amazing that we have
these big Tech platforms Facebook
Twitter Google colluding with the FBI
with the government to censor silence D
platform conservatives and others with
whom they disagree including the oldest
newspaper in America the New York Post
and it was this Jim Baker who just
happens to be the Forrest Gump of all
these scandals he was the guy behind the
Russian collusion hoax with Sussman and
then he shows up at Twitter and he's
he's the guy pushing the censorship of
the of the New York Post and by the way
Miranda this kind of he calls himself I
guess a former Republican now this guy
Matt Dowd he's saying that this was all
kind of a good thing for that Twitter
did this watch this
what amazes me is the Elon Musk might
have spent a little more time reading
the First Amendment and what it said
because his immediate thing was this was
a violation from the first amendment
when it's far as I can tell no
government Authority told Twitter not to
do something it was amazing to me that
all of these sort of Fox News or whoever
else jumped on this without ever fully
understanding that it was basically
meaningless what happened and that
actually turned out to be a good thing
Miranda
well I guess maybe he doesn't understand
that if the FBI goes to Twitter and
instructs them or persuades them to
pre-bunk a New York Post story to
pre-censor it then that is a violation
of the First Amendment
um I I do agree in one sense that Elon
Musk did not release anything that was
really useful when it comes to the FBI's
intervention and I wonder if that is
because James Baker is still there and I
assume that Elon Musk had to get his
release of various documents cleared by
Twitter's lawyers before they went to
mat taibi so maybe
Twitter's lawyers only allowed one
little email from James Baker that had
all the identifying the date the time
all shown from it which was very
interesting and the other thing about
James Baker that we need to remember is
that he also between the FBI and Twitter
went to work for the lawfare blog which
is um you know attached to the Brookings
institution where a number of the 51
former Intel operatives who signed that
dirty letter that dishonest letter
saying that our story and Hunter Biden's
laptop was a Russian disinformation
operation so he's connected to them as
well he is Jonathan Turley called him
the Kevin Bacon of Russian collusion
six degrees of separation or James Baker
all right they tried to kind of deflect
from the Twitter Revelations and I think
Miranda's right they need the raw data
to come out but they're doing it by
saying well Trump is the guy who's
anti-constitution and one of the MSNBC
hosts this morning had a message for
Republicans watch here's the thing like
for Republicans like let's let's get a
let's spell it out for you why don't you
write this down okay to terminate the
Constitution is to terminate America
Donald Trump is wrong and I can no
longer support him at all as a
presidential candidate as an American
citizen that was the tamest of what she
said but uh
what about that like Trump comes out and
says you know puts looks like he was
kind of doing it in Jess but saying well
they couldn't you know install me or
have a new election was that was that
subverting the constitution
I I I'm not even following what her
argument is here I mean I think what
we've seen when we have the FBI working
with big Tech to censor Americans that
is about as against the Constitution as
you can get it's a clear First Amendment
violation so I'm just not even
understanding where she's going well
Miranda I always find it rich when the
Democrats are saying we care about the
Constitution when they want to invent
rights in the Constitution that don't
exist they want to eviscerate the Second
Amendment the first amendment is Mike
says means really nothing unless their
views are the ones that are always
preeminent so suddenly like well you're
against the Constitution like you think
all those guys who wrote it are racist
okay that's what they think Miranda
close it
look what the Democrats are best at is
projecting they accuse you of the crimes
that they commit themselves so if you
want to know what the Democrats are up
to just look at what they're accusing
the Republicans of doing that's a good
one random Mike great to see you both we
spent Friday night together too hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else